你有两种选择
一种是花几天时间听或者阅读迈克尔卡沃尔的这本书
跳过30年的学习曲线
另一种像我一样花上几年
十几年甚至30年的时间将信息碎片整理在一起
慢慢寻找赚钱的策略
答案在你心中
Keep it simple
Stupid
欢迎订阅
按赞
留言和转发
谢谢你
趋势跟踪15第一部分
第二章
伟大的趋势交易者
理查德唐奇安
理查德·唐奇安被尊称为趋势跟踪之父
他最初建立的技术交易系统
后来成了其他趋势跟踪者的交易体系的基础
从1949年成立基金管理公司一直到去世
他都不断地和其他趋势跟踪者分享他的研究成果
给予他们指导
1905年
唐奇安出生于康涅狄格州的哈特福德
他1928年从耶鲁大学毕业
获得经济学学士学位
他对交易十分着迷
尽管在1929年的大萧条中他备受损失
但他还是重返华尔街
继续交易
到了1930年
唐齐安筹集了一些资金做股票交易
他看好一家叫澳本汽车的公司
威廉鲍尔温在文章中提到
那时唐齐安认为
这家公司就像后来的苹果电脑
他在这笔交易中赚了几千美元
成了名副其实的技术分析人士
他从图表中观察价格
制定买卖策略
而不考虑公司的内在价值
我们从1968年用打孔机的时候
就开始建立数据库了
收集的商品期货行情数据
一直回溯到1959年7月
我们按照唐奇安的想法
选定5周和20周作为时间区间
进行每周回测
我认为每周回测
是所有人都可以用的好方法
唐奇安实现了每周回测
这帮助我们识别出有效趋势
并迅速行动
唐齐安是那种手算就可以打败电脑的人
丹尼斯·蒂登恩
从1933年到1935年
唐齐安为海姆菲尔诺伊斯公司撰写技术分析评论
后来在第二次世界大战中
他在美国空军负责统计
战争结束后
又重回华尔街
为希尔森哈密尔公司撰写分析评论
他开始详细分析期货价格
在分类账册上记录每日的价格数据
他的学生巴巴拉迪克森
巴伯·蒂克森注意到他计算移动平均线
手工绘制图表
在没有精确的数据库
软件和任何计算工具的情况下
生成交易信号
他的夹克口袋里
总有一支铅笔和一个卷笔刀
狄克森的描述让我们很清楚地了解到
唐齐安的工作多么超前
远胜过那些现代学院派金融理论家所做的工作
哈佛大学的约翰·林特纳·詹·林特纳
曾提出把期货加进股票和债券投资组合中
并对此做了量化分析但在这之前邓恩早就已经在实践中运用了分散投资和风险控制的思想而后来威廉夏普William Sharp和哈里马克维茨
Harry Markowitz还以此获得了1990年诺贝尔经济学奖
坚持不屑
理查德·唐奇安并非一夜成名
他42岁的时候还只管理着20万美元的资金
但到了60多岁的时候
机缘巧合
他迎来了后继勃发的时刻
十年时间
他在希尔森公司管理2700万美元的资产
每年能从用金和手续费中赚100万美元
另外
自己的基金每年也能赚100万美元
大约是1979年或者1980年
在一次骂会议上
我遇见了19位做CTA的公募基金经理
我认出其中的16位都是和唐启安有来往的
他们要么是曾与他共事
要么是和他有投资关系
在我看来
这是他早年影响力的证明
唐奇安总是会因为他的朋友取得了杰出成绩而感到自豪
在很长一段时间里
唐奇安的声音都是非主流的
但如今呢
他的思想已经成了这个领域的权威思想
他也一定会因此而感到自豪的
布拉特·埃拉姆
Bright Allen
唐奇安从不预测价格的变动方向
他只是跟随
他对成功的阐释简单易懂
就像道士理论所说的那样
在趋势中坚持
他补充道
很多人会说黄金要开始跌了
因为它涨得太快之类的话
这也正是85%的投资者都会亏钱的原因
基本面分析者可能会觉得同样涨价
但我只要看到趋势向下
就坚持看空唐齐安的经典交易法则
从第一次公开出版到现在
已经超过了75年
但其中的智力永不过时
通用法则
一 如果市场上有广泛认可的观点 要迅速行动
就算观点是正确的 通常市场也会延迟反应
二 在交易不活跃的时期 仔细观察 随时准备
当成交量放大时就跟随趋势而动
打破幻觉要比找到真理更能让你变得睿智
路德维希伯恩·拉德维克波恩
三 懂得止损 让收益增长 别的就不用管了
四 在方向不确定的时候 保证金可以少放些
趋势的变动会频繁出现
让市场精彩无比
而你要做的是关注趋势变动
这样可以防止两头都受损失
五
不要一看到两三天的趋势就冲进市场
再等等等出现日内反转
六
用好止损单对交易很有益处
止损单可以用于保证盈利
限制损失
或者出现特定波形时加减仓
止损单应该和图表分析一起使用
这对交易大有益处
7.如果市场上的上行和下行势能基本相当
那么应该在上行趋势上投中仓
这是基于收益率的判断从50跌到25只亏损50%但从25涨到50就能盈利100%8.开仓时用限价委托是可行的停仓时则用市价委托
9.买入主力期货合约
卖掉弱势合约
具体交易结合其他规则而定
10.跟随一个强的趋势
要比跟随弱的趋势更值得一博
11.研究公司的股本结构
某个事件的影响程度
以及该事件到底是好事还是坏事
这和研究财务报告一样重要
唐齐安法则
一 价格朝某个方向运动一段时间后
就会横盘整理
然后再次朝同样的方向运动
运动的幅度和上一次的幅度大致相当
通常在第二次运动快要结束时
价格就更可能朝着相反的方向运动了
二 趋势反转或者趋势逆行
可能会在下列情况中出现
A 到达某个点位
而这一点位在过去出现过长时间的剧烈震荡
B.到达一段时间的高点或者低点
3.在趋势线靠拢时
随时关注买入或卖出的机会
尤其是在成交量中等偏下的时候
你要确保所选择的趋势线不会太频繁的交叉和靠拢
4.随时关注主要或次要趋势线缓慢上行或颠簸上行
在趋势线突破时准备买入或卖出
5.次要趋势线突破主要趋势线是最重要的仓位改变信号
在这个点位上你要考虑好开仓还是平仓
6.三线合一可能意味着刀弱反弹或势能分散
这要是情况而定
但通常随后都会出现趋势突破
7.注意成交量的变化
尤其是在趋势已经持续了很长一段时间之后
8.不要在缺口回补之前关注缺口
除非你真能分清跳空缺口
普通缺口和衰竭缺口
九 在趋势中
你应该在出现日内反转后的第二个交易日开盘时
进行开仓和加仓操作
不管反转的幅度如何
你都应该这么做
尤其是在反转时成交量缩小的情况下
唐齐安的学生巴巴拉迪克森
是一名功成名就的女性趋势交易者
她1969年从瓦萨学院毕业
但因为她是女性学的又是历史专业
因此没有人愿意雇他当股票经纪人
但尽管如此
他最终还是在希尔森公司找到了一份工作
给唐齐安做秘书
狄克森在唐齐安身边工作的这三年
得到了唐齐安的亲自指导
其价值难以估量
1973年在唐齐安搬到康涅狄格州时
他就自己出去开公司了
不久他就管理了40多个客户的账户
每个账户的资金从2万美元到100万美元不等
迪克森注意到了唐奇安在交易方面化繁为简的天才思维
我不是数学家
我相信简单的方法反而蕴藏着极致的优雅没有谁能用复杂的数学公式解答市场到底是上涨下跌还是是震荡。但是要想定义清楚这三种情况,没有什么方法能比价格图表更简单了。
从20世纪70年代开始,我就用这种方法思考有人能准确知道什么时候会出现趋势吗?
没有。
有人能准确知道如何做一笔肯定赚钱的交易吗?
实际上,大量的交易都是基于某个时间序列所服从的概率分布的。
如果你看看保险 赌博或者其他任何的商业活动
你就会得出这样的结论
任何一个小领域都能赚大钱 某论坛
唐奇安还向别人讲授快速和简单决策的重要性
在这方面 他再次领先于同时代的其他交易者
迪克森从唐奇安那里学到了
一个好的交易系统应该让你在没有趋势时
还能在市场上活得好好的 而不至于血本无归
他解释说交易系统存在的目的就是能在趋势确立的时候告诉你进场
不要在一连串损失之后就抛弃你的交易体系
这很重要
因为没有交易体系就没有收益迪克森从来不做价格的变动预测
也从来不期待每次交易都能赚钱
他知道预测趋势到底还是到底是不可能的
趋势会不断出现
而从长期来看你能以此赚钱
失败一次并不重要
你要做的只是承认失败
然后继续交易
现在很多交易者还盯着新闻不放
听那些突然报复的新贵们讲解投资经验
而我呢
还是更喜欢回头去读唐奇安的话
可谓字字珠基
常读常新
这比CNBC的节目好多了
我最喜欢唐奇安在一次发言中
面对许多仍然在交易中苦苦挣扎的人
所表现出的智慧
你交易的是股票还是大豆期货
这一点都不重要
交易就是交易
是赚钱的游戏而已
交易者的职责很简单
不要亏钱
不亏钱才是最重要的
而不是我要做好研究
研究也可以好好做
但是你要先仔细考虑清楚
研究本身并不能为你赚钱
但最终你的目标恐怕还是围绕着钱
而不是在如何阅读资产负债表上
拿个ABA理查德唐奇安这般直言不讳的说话方式
可能也是为什么
长青藤大学的金融课程
都不愿意提到他的原因吧
总结
唐奇安在1929年股灾中损失惨重
唐奇安在第二次世界大战中
曾为五角大楼工作
他和美国前国防部长
罗伯特·麦克纳玛拉
有过紧密合作
唐奇安直到65岁
才成立他的趋势跟踪基金
他到90多岁还在做交易
而且自己亲自实践了
很多趋势跟踪的方法
另外
在那个女性在华尔街
不被尊重的年代
他就培训女性做交易员了
没有谁能够用复杂的数学公式解答
市场到底会上涨
下跌还是震荡
唐奇安
没有人能否认凹凸不平的结构无处不在
本华曼德博